freddie peralta against his very
talented dodger lineup trying to keep it
rolling here rock yeah two-and-oh is
freddie peralta 245 earned run average
look at these strikeout totals
38 punch house 22 innings could use one
here 2-2 pitch
popped him up
jackie bradley jr is over
and peralta strands a pair in the first
inning
brewer's coming up dodgers fail to score
it'll be wong vogelback and narvaez to
get us started major league debut for
edwin ucetta 23 years old out of the
dominican republic but they loved what
he was doing at the alternate site where
he's been built up to give him some
length here
that's soft bouncing ball to first
charging muncie goes to second they go
back to first and nobody's trying to
catch it but
they catch a break now they've shoveled
it back to turner and narvaez
made a move towards second
making himself tagable and turner did
good job by justin turner tell you what
when you hear that in a scouting report
with a young pitcher that gets your
attention that's a bullet
avi garcia lines one to left field maybe
a sign of things to come
he's been working so hard rock trying to
get through this slump get his timing
back his rhythm that looked like a good
swing
roussetta shrugs his shoulders he's
ready kicks fires and he strikes out
shaw swinging
93 middle middle fastball and shaw
is the first major league strikeout
victim for edwin usa
right at him with a fastball
remember that
the rest of your
life sitting around your friends are
going to ask you
who's a
first guy you struck out jackie bradley
jr is going to be the batter
swinging in a fly ball to ride in deep
get up
get up get out of here gone
for jackie bradley jr
and the brewers have a two-nothing lead
bradley goes yard
with garcia
aboard
and that is number 100
in the career
of jackie bradley jr how about that one
folks he got it all
and knocked it out of here by plenty
ah big day
for jackie bradley jr absolutely he knew
he got it
1-1 from ucenta swung on lifted in the
air to left field shallow and it's not
going to be playable for pollock he'll
throw to third base and they have
glorious oh he called him safe
the ball beat him by 10 minutes
and third base umpire stu sherwater
jawing with justin turner right now
turner thought he made the tag the third
base umpires too sure water was blocked
out the tag was made on the right
shoulder and it was made well before the
hand the hand was eight inches away from
being placed upon the bag this will be
overturned major league debut today 0-2
curve ball struck him out high breaker
the new set up
let go by strikeout number two for
freddie peralta
a swing adam is fastball from peralta
and
three consecutive k's for freddie
peralta now two outs here in the third
inning basketball really coming to life
here check this out right on the edge
maybe a little off at 96 miles an hour
and only getting taylor on strikes tried
to pull it came off empty
aj pollock leading off the fifth for the
dodgers down two nothing
and crushing the ball to left center
field forget about it
and the dodgers on the board here in the
fifth
dj pollock with a home run
his second of the season dodgers get on
the board it's 2-1
a 3-2 pitch and pollock
just absolutely hammered it to left
that ball was pounded it was hit into
the second deck above the bullpens
working here in the sixth he's retired
13 of his last 14 batters
first ball swinging taylor into center
field jbj is there for out
number one
one pitch and one out speaking of
efficiency
kind of puts a little pressure on this
guy after the guy in front of him
swings to the first one he's going to go
for it anyway right off the end of the
bat two pitches two outs
now i would imagine now justin turner's
gonna take one or two got to how about a
three-pitch inning for freddie 3-2 the
count
two outs in the inning turner a swing at
a miss
got him with a fastball
one two three inning for peralta after
the homer he's retired six in a row with
three strikeouts garcia waits on deck
gonzalez deals narvaez hits a bullet
through that shift a base hit
narvaez thinking two nope he'll pull up
the reigns settle for a single
omar keeps it going and that
gives the brewers that match up they're
looking for
boy omar grabbing at his left hand
he's not doing good oh man
brewers already have one catcher on the
injured list manny pina with the
toe injury
and imagine they
are going to let him ride this one out
no he's leaving for the brewers just
cannot can't catch a break get a break
in the injury front you're right big
spot right here the brewers could use a
big moment from casting hira
a former all-star closer in trying and
roberts
going with him in the seventh to face
hira
two outs two one brewers lead
not a no one from trinity
it's a soft bouncing ball to short corey
seeger takes a hop that was deadened a
nice play
on a difficult little rolling hop there
and trynan's on to the inning without
further damage jp fyrizen comes in the
dodgers down a run as we go to the
eighth is one out of taylor
drops down an in ball two no he went
around long long
dave roberts
you already have that block that we
talked about that's frustrating the call
that we never see so he's gonna go hold
on a minute has he already been thrown
out i don't know if i've ever seen a
manager go all the way to the first base
um player on a check swing
if he's not already thrown out that may
be the goal here
we're getting word that he has been
ejected not gonna get his money's worth
fire rising against taylor three two two
out eighth inning here he comes
and he popped him up
back is garcia
getting over
three outs in the air one strike
delivery on colton wong
sends one fair down the left field line
bouncing off the
infield cover in the second base he goes
with a sliding leadoff double
colton wong
rifled one just inside the line it's
heard
well there he is
gotta move him along at least wong with
great speed at third and mainly a
bouncing ball wong's coming to the plate
no play at the plate they get the out at
first but wong scores what a jump
goodness gracious
he talked about colton wong and his base
running abilities it's not just about
speed it's instinct
haters got him o2
deals it and a swing at a miss he struck
him out
fastball this time
three pitches and seeger is going out
number one here in the night now hater
trying to take it to the finish line
2-2 hater fires and a cold strike three
back-to-back case
one strike away
hater fires and a swing at a miss and
the ball game is over
josh hader delivers again